welcome to my presentation on order of
operations so we're gonna do now is give
you a structure how you should tackle a
mathematical expression when it's maybe
not initially clear on on I guess what
you should do first let me give you an
example if I were to tell you whoops I'm
using the wrong color again okay so if I
had seven plus two times three how do
you interpret that you know one person
might say okay I'm going to add seven
plus two and get so let's see this is
one way I could interpret it I could say
this is seven plus two so that would be
nine times three
and so that would be 27 but another
person could say no no no no I think we
should do the multiplication first we
should do the two times three first and
two times three is six of course and
then we get 7 plus 6 and 7 plus 6 is 13
so who did it who did it the right way
do you just go straight left to right or
for some reason whatever you do
multiplication first and I mean we can't
do it both ways because clearly we don't
we don't like to get two different
answers for the for the same problem
because otherwise how can we mark
people's questions wrong no no no
because we always want to just be
consistent with each other but anyway so
what is the correct way of heck tackling
this problem and that this is what the
order of operations are all about and I
will now tell you what they are
so the first thing you should worry
about when you look when you do order of
operations is exponents X whoops no no
no no I I forget parentheses is first
parentheses that whenever you see
parentheses that tells you do this first
then exponents and if you don't know
what an exponent is don't worry I'll
show you some examples probably not in
this video but in the next one after
this because this one is for more a
general or a younger crowd
then you do multiplication Maul mult a
multiplication and division and then you
do addition and subtraction so let's do
a couple so parentheses exponents
multiplication division addition
subtraction
the way I think about in parentheses I
think will almost make sense to you they
force you to do that part first and then
you kind of do the faster operations
first you know exponents will increase
the number very very quickly while no
man I have a I have a call oh never I'm
gonna ignore it cuz you're more
important anyway you know exponents are
kind of a very fast operation right the
numbers getting big very fast
multiplication and division
they're a little less fast an addition
and subtraction are kind of like the
slowest way of operating on numbers
that's how I think about it I apologize
if that happens to confuse you so let's
let's do some examples I think that this
is all about practice so watch this
video and then do a ton of practice
problems preferably on Khan Academy and
it should make some sense so let me see
I'm using a new tool for these recording
these videos so it's ok here we go so
let's say I had 3 plus 5 minus 3 times 6
divided by 2 that's divided by I could
have written a division sign there too
so what do i do first I have all these
numbers there's a bunch of different
ways I can pack them well if you
remember what I just wrote down
parenthesis always first so let's tackle
the parenthesis so we tackled this part
first ok that's fine but now even within
the parentheses I'm not sure what I do
first so I'm in the parentheses and then
within the parentheses well let's see I
could do subtraction first I could do
multiplication first and if you remember
what I just wrote we would do the
multiplication first so this is what we
will tackle first the 3 times 6 and so 3
times 6 is obviously 18 so then the
expression becomes 3 plus 5 minus 18
right / - and I could I could write it
like that's % / I'll write it / like
that but it could be that / - I guess
I'm always programming computer that's
why I'm used to they do this divided /
this is a division sign just in case you
don't know ok so back to what we had
done before we still have a fairly
complicated expression especially
because I wrote it so messy over here so
what do I do next
well once again parentheses first
parentheses first
so we go into this parentheses and
there's only one thing I can do within
this parentheses is I can do five minus
18 well what's five minus 18 it's
negative 13 so now I have three plus
minus 13/2 right and our next and I
could even well I'll leave the
parentheses there but you know I'm just
having parentheses around numbers so
might the next thing is do what do I do
next I do the addition or do I do the
division first and actually what I was
just thinking about this house tempted
to do this first but no division comes
ahead of addition correct could division
and multiplication are kind of the same
I got kind of the same speed that's how
I view them and addition and subtraction
are are slower so we do a division first
so we do the third negative 13 divided
by 2 so we get 3 plus so that you know
this goes to this and now we want to do
the 13 divided by 2
what's negative 13 divided by 2 it's
minus six point five so it's minus six
point five all right that became minus
six point five and now there's nothing
left to do we have three plus minus six
point five well that is minus 3.5 and we
are done
that was a little complicated but all
you have to remember we did the
parentheses first and rendering went
within the parentheses we did we said
are there any other parentheses no but
there's multiplication so we did the
multiplication we got here then we just
did the rest of the parentheses we got
to negative 13 then we did the division
before the addition we got here and then
we just simplify the problem let's do
another one because I want your brain to
hurt if I can just learn how to use this
tool I'm using okay
what if I had three plus five times two
- three times six ah well the first
thing we always look for is the
parentheses and so we go into this
parentheses we see this big parentheses
and then within that parentheses there
are more parentheses so we keep kind of
focusing in and we see this parenthesis
right here unless so this is the
parentheses within the parentheses so
that's what we'll always want to do
first and so the value of three plus
five well that's easy that's eight so
then we get eight times two minus three
times six
all right because we just took this
three plus five just became this eight
and what's when we do next well we once
again we have parenthesis so we do
whatever inside the parentheses first we
do the eight times two and eight times
two is sixteen so now we have 16 minus
three times six
now what do we do next we do the
subtraction first or do we do the
multiplication first well we do we do
the multiplication because
multiplication comes ahead of
subtraction remember parentheses first
then multiplication and division then
addition and subtraction so let's do
this next so we have 16 minus three
times 6 that's 16 minus 18 16 minus 18
is minus two that's how we did it now
let me ask you a question I'm gonna ask
you something that should hopefully be
vaguely thought-provoking if I have two
times three times five does it matter
whether I do two times three first or
three times five first
well let lets let's test this out if we
do two times three first two times three
first we get six and then we type that
times five if we do the three times five
first we have two times 15 and then 6
times 5 is 30
and two times 15 is also 30 it didn't
matter and and and
you might say well maybe it only worked
for this the Sal you fixed the numbers
you picked the exact numbers that would
not matter which way I did it and what
I'm going to leave you as an exercise is
to try it with any group of random
numbers and then you'll see that when
you're doing only things of one level if
this was all multiplication and division
it wouldn't matter what order you did a
mint left to right and that's why in
order of operations you put
multiplication and division at the same
level the same thing is true of addition
and subtraction you know if you if I had
1 plus 2 minus 3 plus 5 it doesn't
matter what order I do this in as long
as I do the operations and I'll get to
the same answer the order of operations
only matter when you start mixing the
multiplication and the subtraction and
the parentheses together that's all I
have time for right now have fun do some
practice and I might record another
video soon